Now, let's walk through the basic workflow of a project environment so that you can
gain a better understanding of source control collaboration in action.
First, let's meet our team.
Developer A, an artist.
Developer B, another artist.
Their team lead, Developer C. And finally, the star of the show, the depot or server.
Now, Developer A is super good at flowers, but not so much at sims, so it's time to
team up with Developer B and get to work making the total flower package.
First, Developer A creates a file locally.
This is the flower asset that she's going to work on, but before she starts, she needs
to add the file to the depot.
This tells the depot to start tracking the flower and to include it on any submissions
or updates.
Developer A then works locally, and when she's finished working on the flower, she
uploads the finished file to the depot with a description, submitting it, and creating
a version.
Now, Developer B gets updated and downloads the latest version from the depot locally
to their machine.
This gives Developer B an exact copy of the version that Developer A submitted.
Developer B is now ready to do their thing and put that stem on the flower.
So they start by checking out the flower, and that in turn locks the flower on the
depot so that Developer B can start modifying the flower and add that stem.
Now, checking out the file doesn't really prevent others from modifying the file, but
it does prevent them from checking it out.
This means that Developer B doesn't have to yell across the room to let Developer
A know that they are working on the flower, so they really shouldn't try to change
it.
Developer B gets to work, and in no time, he has modified the flower and saved it locally.
The stem is glorious, and the revision is ready to be submitted.
So once again, the file is submitted and versioned.
This new version now becomes the head revision or the latest revision for the flower.
Once the flower is updated, the other team members will see that the file they have
is now out of date.
So if they try to modify it, they're going to be warned, and they'll need to jump through
some hoops in order to save that file.
Instead, the team will just update the copies that they've got locally.
So Developer A will pull a new version and update her copy.
Next, the team lead will pull the latest version for review, and he's happy with
the results.
Now the entire team is on the same page and ready to party.
Okay, that's an ideal example, but let's say the team lead takes the flower to a director
and they aren't happy.
So the team repeats the process and goes through several notes to make multiple changes on
the flower, pushing four or five iterations to the depot, eventually creating a version
that results in a happy director.
Unfortunately, the director, after seeing the results on camera, changes their mind
and decides that where we ended up was not great.
In fact, the director asks the team to go back to a second version, and it looks
like that was the best version on screen.
So in Perforce, you can revert to that in multiple ways, but the end result of reverting
to the second iteration will actually create a sixth iteration, since the update to that
file will be non-destructive to the other versions, just in case someone changes their
mind one more time.
That's it for the basic workflow and project environment.
I hope this helps with your understanding of source control, and in our next section,
we will explore the server and client setup as we look at working with the Perforce client.